khloe kardashian reacts to people
calling her daughter true thompson quote
big and says she doesn't want her
three-year-old to face the same
insecurities and struggles that she did
growing up coco covers the november
issue of health and inside the mag the
37 year old reality star opens up about
parenting her little girl whom she
shares with her ex tristan thompson
quote when it comes to food i had so
many issues it wasn't from one person i
guess just from society or how people
critiqued my body and because of that
the good american founder says she
doesn't mess around when it comes to
true i'm not taking any from anyone
quote she's very tall people will say
she's so big and i'll say oh she's so
tall i try to make them be more
descriptive i know what an adult means
when they say that but i don't want her
to misinterpret that chloe adds that
despite being young true is quote really
tough quote sometimes i'll notice she
may bump into something i'll say are you
okay tutu and she'll say yes and kind of
brush it off i do try to always tell her
that it's okay if she cries or if
something is wrong and one lesson that
chloe is always instilling in her
daughter the importance of family i feel
so lucky true is super close with her
cousins kylie jenner's daughter stormy
webster kim kardashian's daughter
chicago west and rob kardashian's
daughter dream who are all close in age
and just like how coco and her sisters
are inseparable chloe says that's
exactly what they want for their kids
quote we're raising the cousins to
almost feel like they're siblings and
speaking of siblings chloe says with
time she realizes just how lucky she is
to be so close to her family quote the
older i get the more and more i realize
what an incredible relationship i have
with each one of my siblings it's
totally cheesy but i am so in love with
each one of them
[Music]
you